in Stanford and Princeton and numerous
other universities in college as also
large businesses have sent funds back to
us and in some cases I stopped funds
that I looked at and we are pleased to
report that the funds have either not
gone out or it's about three hundred and
fifty million dollars and they've either
not gun out or we've renegotiated it and
they're not getting them so in a couple
of cases they're sending them back and
sending them back immediately so I think
it was very nice I want to thank offered
in particular they acted very quickly
and decisively and they agreed when they
heard the facts that they should not be
getting it so we appreciate it very much
from Harvard Princeton Stanford and
other institutions the bill also
includes 30 billion dollars to support
small lending institutions serving
distressed communities helping countless
African American and Hispanic American
small businesses as we continue our
battle against the virus the data and
facts on the ground suggest that we're
making great progress in 23 states new
cases have declined in the peak week
forty percent of American counties have
also seen a rapid decline in new cases
46 states reported drop in patients
showing coronavirus like symptoms that's
a big number to keep America gaining
momentum every citizen needs to maintain
the vigilance and we all understand that
very well well we've gone over it many
many times this includes practicing good
hygiene maintaining social distance and
the voluntary use of face covering my
safe and phased reopening of our economy
it's very exciting but does not mean
that we are letting down our guard at
all in any way on the contrary continued
diligence is an essential part of our
strategy to get our country back to work
to take our country back we're winning
this and we're going to win it and we're
going to keep watching we're gonna watch
very closely for the invisible enemy
with each passing day we're learning
more and more about
this enemy the scientists at DHS have
released a report offering a number of
insights about how the virus reacts to
different temperatures climates and
surfaces the findings confirm that the
virus survives better and colder and
drier environments and does less well in
warmer and more humid environments I
have to say that very excitingly we're
going to have somebody up the bill will
be up in just a little while
it was a great report you gave and he's
going to be talking about how the virus
reacts in sunlight you only hear the
numbers you won't even believe them us
trials of the kovat 19 have been going
on and have been approved in the United
States Germany UK and China it's big
news and we're a lot of trials are going
on we have a lot of great brilliant
minds working on this both from the
standpoint of a vaccine and therapeutics
we must be careful in all conditions but
we will we will get this done we're very
close to a vaccine unfortunately we're
not very close to testing because when
the testing starts it takes a period of
time but we'll get it done and I want to
thank the head of DHS Science and
Technology bill Bryant for what he's
going to be doing and what he's going to
be saying and the report that he's about
to give I think it's going to be
something that nobody's ever heard it'll
be brand new information a very
important information my administration
continues to leverage the defense
production act to dramatically increase
the manufacturing delivery of critical
medical supplies we finalized three
contracts to produce 39 million more and
95 masks and 90 days and as you know
we're also using a sterilization process
some great equipment that will sterilize
the masks up to 20 times per mask so
that's like ordering 20 times more masks
and it's working very well we just want
the hospitals and the institutions where
it is to use it a lot of people don't
use it they're so used to getting a new
mask
they don't want to use it they want to
go and immediately get a new one we're
asking them to use the sterilization
process every bit as good up to 20 times
think of that in addition to ramping up
our domestic assembly lines we also have
airlift at nearly 750 million pieces of
personal protective equipment into the
United States through our project air
bridge which has been an incredible
thing to watch it's really a military
operation the vice president is now
providing each governor with an
exhaustive count by county breakdown of
the privately distributed personal
protection and and this is equipment and
things that are incredible if it's
personal protective equipment it's
incredible and it's all brand new and at
the highest level we're getting only the
highest level and also we're looking at
essential gear within their states and
it's being delivered to different states
quickly and as we speak this way the
governor should know exactly what's
being delivered through a private sector
supply chain within their states as well
as through to the project air bridge
we're trying to get it immediately from
the plane to the state where we can't do
that we bring it into our facilities and
get it to the governor's and we're
getting him fast and we're notifying a
very strongly so they know it's there
governor's can use this information to
quickly ensure that they get materials
where and when they are needed today I
also want to extend my special thanks to
our nation's incredible County Emergency
Management teams who have been working
relentlessly for weeks around-the-clock
end-on-end
to serve their communities help
distribute critical supplies and save
countless American lives we salute these
heroic officials on the front lines as
we continue to develop potential
therapies the FDA has recently begun a
national effort to expand access to
convalescent plasma donated from the
blood of those who have recovered from
the virus the blood of these donors
contains antibodies that can potentially
reduce the severity of the illness and
those who are sick and frankly those
that
very sick nearly three thousand patients
are now enrolled in the expanded access
program receiving transfusions
nationwide and I want to thank all of
the people that recovered for what
they've done they as I said yesterday
they raised their hand when they barely
can walk and they're saying I want to
donate blood I want to donate whatever
it is that you want because we want to
help people it's really quite incredible
convalescent plasma will also be used to
manufacture a concentrated antibody
treatment that does not have to be
matched with a particular blood type
this concentrated antibody treatment
could be used as a preventative measure
to keep health care workers and other
high risk populations from contracting
the virus in the first place very big
deal clinical trials of these products
are slated to begin within weeks and we
can maybe have a fairly quick solution I
urge Americans to get in there and keep
doing what you're doing because again we
want those people recovering or
recovered from coronavirus to contact
their local blood and plasma donation
center to learn how they can help and
they've been so great and I just
appreciate it my administration is also
partnered with the leading and we have
really been establishing some great
partnerships with leading technology
companies and scientific journals to
create a database of 52,000 scholarly
articles on the virus that can be
analyzed by artificial intelligence top
AI experts are now using this wealth of
data to gain insights into potential
therapies and we're collaborating with
tech firms universities in our national
labs to harness American supercomputers
in the search for treatments and
vaccines that search is going on and
it's being I think you'll see in the
future you'll see it's very successful
ultimately it'll be a tremendous success
great progress is being made at a rapid
pace a pace like no other we have every
hope that with the full might and
resources of American science and
technology and with the courage and
devotion of the American people who have
been so incredible we will end this
plague and together we will reach
or the full measure of American strength
and power and prosperity our country is
going to do fantastically well you see
what's going on there is a pent-up
demand in our country to get it back
right where it was and maybe even better
and that's what's going to happen so
with that I'd like to ask Mike Pence to
come up vice president say a few words
please Mike Thank You mr. president and
good afternoon today the White House
coronavirus task force met and while our
hearts are with the families of those
who have lost their life to the
coronavirus and those who are struggling
with serious illness today our team led
by dr. deborah birx informs us that the
data continues to show promising signs
of progress in new york metro area New
Jersey Connecticut Detroit and New
Orleans all appear to be past their peak
and we are seeing consistent declines in
hospitalization and cases in regions
across the country our only conclusion
is that we're getting there America
because the American people have put
into practice the president's guidelines
of social distancing because you've been
listening and adhering to the guidance
of state and local officials we are
we're making we're making meaningful
progress in a very real sense pairing
Americans to be exposed to the
coronavirus and no less extent saving
lives our task force actually believes
mr. president that if we continue these
mitigation efforts in the days ahead
as States implement their policies
including phased reopening that will
preserve those gains we do believe by
early summer we could be in a much
better place as a nation with with much
of this coronavirus epidemic behind us
earlier today we also had a conference
call led by secretary ben Carson and
leaders from HUD about the president's
announcement yesterday that he is
repurposing the White House opportunity
and revitalization Council to focus on
the M
of the coronavirus on minority
communities secretary Carson will
convene the council tomorrow and will be
reporting tomorrow afternoon on their
progress we want to thank more than 270
leaders of organizations dedicated to
housing homelessness and improving the
lives of people across our urban
communities not only for being with us
today
for the way they have partnered with our
administration and partnered with state
and local officials to put the health of
all of their constituencies first as the
president mentioned will you'll receive
a report that our task force received
formally this week from bill Bryant of
the Science and Technology Directorate
at the Department of Homeland Security
he will outline as the president said
encouraging news about the impact that
heat and sunlight have on the
coronavirus which will increase the
confidence that we feel about the coming
summer on the subject of testing at the
present moment we have reports of four
point nine three million tests having
been performed across America and
encouraging news as states have been
engaging commercial labs at a higher
level across the country yesterday our
commercial lab system did more than one
hundred thousand tests in a single day
so we're beginning to activate all of
the capacity and tomorrow at the
president's direction our task force
will convene a conference call with all
of the nation's governor's to talk about
their progress that they are making on
testing and we're going to hear from
governor's about the practices that and
methods that they are employing to
significantly increase testing following
our briefing about capacity and
laboratories this past Monday
for instance Governor Mike DeWine just
announced that Ohio's testing has been
greatly expanded after the FDA approved
thermal Fisher's new extraction reagent
as saying in his words that the action
quote probably doubled maybe even
tripled testing in Ohio virtually
overnight
governor Tim waltz of Minnesota
announced along with the state's
healthcare system the Mayo Clinic and
the University of Minnesota what he
described as a breakthrough for rapid
widespread
he was able to test more than 20,000
people using a molecular test per day
Governor Kim Reynolds of Iowa launched
the test Iowa initiative that will
triple testing capacity by partnering
with noemi health and Domo she also
worked with the University of Iowa
Hospitals to leverage further capacity
and governor Eric Holcomb and Governor
Andy Beshear of Indiana and Kentucky
respectively both announced additional
drive-through testing locations our
priority has always been to focus first
on those impacted by the corona virus
and then on those extraordinary health
care workers ministering to their needs
every day and I know mr. president how
proud you are that the our men and women
in uniform have come alongside our
health care workers in communities most
impacted and I know the American people
are proud as well as of today FEMA
reports at 35,000 National Guard have
been deployed across the country to aid
in our coronavirus response governor
Kevin state of Ohio actually deployed
the National Guard to hospitals across
the state to evaluate protective
equipment and hospital capacity and
report it into State Emergency
Management and FEMA and governor Greg
Abbott of Texas actually mobilized more
than 1,200 National Guard and forty-five
teams to provide greater access to
testing along with the National Guard at
the president's direction today more
than 4,500 active duty military doctors
nurses and medical assistants have been
deployed across the country yesterday
1,013 medical professionals in our
military were actually deployed to 19
hospitals in seven states to support
those amazing health care workers and
with 4.4 million more Americans filing
for unemployment in the past week I
joined the President and welcoming
passage in the House today of the
paycheck protection program it'll
support working families allow small
businesses to keep people on the payroll
for a period of two months but it also
as the president requested included
seventy five billion dollars to assist
hospitals across the country and in that
spirit the president and I will continue
to urge
across the country given the unique
burden on hospitals we are now
encouraging states to restart elective
surgeries wherever possible either
statewide or on a county-by-county basis
we recognize the role elective surgeries
play in finances for local hospitals and
we'll be working with states to enable
that in that vein governor Doug Ducey
exec issued an executive order not long
ago allowing elective surgeries
beginning May 1 for hospitals that meet
certain preparedness criteria and
Indiana's governor Eric Holcomb is
allowing elective clinical procedures to
begin on April 21st finally mr.
president the task force received today
our first report on state re-opening
plans at the present moment 16 states
have released formal reopening plans 13
of those were actually released since
you unveiled the opening up America
guidelines to our governor's into the
nation last week and to your point mr.
president states are beginning to make
those plans and and we're encouraged to
see so many states embracing the phased
approach to reopening their economies
that's contemplated in our guidelines
for opening up America again for
instance Governor Mike parson and
Missouri announced the show-me strong
recovery plan has two initial phases
intended to protect the most at-risk
Governor Tom Wolf's announced the plan
for Pennsylvania that would begin May
8th will end a stay at home order for
just portions of Pennsylvania but the
plan again requires regions to have
fewer than 50 new positive cases per
100,000 for a period of 14 days and it
also lays out a phased reopening roadmap
governor Kate brown of Oregon updated
their framework for reopening doing
three phases again on a county-by-county
basis and governor Brad little of Idaho
released rebound Idaho in just the last
few days that will consist of four
phases and require specific criteria
that Idaho and businesses need
to begin to reopen mr. president with
the with the guidelines to open up
America again states are making plans
and at your direction our task force
will continue work very closely
providing them with the data providing
them with the resources to be able to
implement those plans in a safe and
responsible way so with that let me just
end where I began and to say thank you
to the American people the progress that
we are seeing is a testament to what all
of you have done to our extraordinary
health care workers a partnership
between the federal government and to
state and local official and and I'm
confidence also owing to the prayers of
millions of Americans each and every day
all of that combined we're we're slowing
the spread we're protecting the most
vulnerable we're saving lives and in
every single day we are one day closer
to opening up America again with that
mr. president I'd be pleased to call
bill forward bill Bryant leads the
Science and Technology Directorate at
the Department of Homeland Security and
now we'll make a presentation on their
recent study Thank You mr. vice
president Thank You mr. president for
this opportunity to do this today good
afternoon everybody my name is bill
Bryan and I lead the Science and
Technology Directorate at the US
Department of Homeland Security over the
last several months we've intensified
the department's Rd efforts to identify
and deliver information that informs our
response to covert 19s NT is working to
identify develop deploy and deploy the
tools and information to support our
response to this crisis as part of our
efforts we're leveraging the unique
capabilities of SM T's national bio
defense analysis and countermeasures
center to study the biology of the Cova
19 virus this Center is a high bio
containment laboratory located in
Frederick Maryland
it was established in the early 2000s in
response to the Ameri tracks attacks and
where we studied characterize analyze
and develop countermeasures for
biological threats to the homeland we
work closely with the CDC FDA HHS and
also our Department of Defense
colleagues and many others
yesterday I shared the emerging results
of our work that we're doing now with
the coronavirus task force and today I
would like to share certain trends that
we believe are important if I may have
the first slide please
and while that's coming up our most
striking observation to date is the
powerful effect that solar light appears
to have on killing the virus both
surfaces and in the air we've seen a
similar effect with both temperature and
humidity as well we're increasing the
temperature and humidity or both is
generally less favorable to the virus so
let me illustrate with this first slide
if you look to the right you'll see that
term half life with a bunch of time
stamps on there first let me tell you
what a half life is we don't measure the
virus as far how long will it live on
the surface we have to measure the decay
of the virus in terms of its half-life
because we don't know certain elements
we don't know how much a person expect
rates when he when he spits right when
he sneezes whatever the case may be we
don't know how much virus is in there so
it's that that has a long bearing on how
long the virus is going to be alive and
active so we measure in half-life cuz
half-life doesn't change so if you look
at an 18 hour half-life which are
basically saying is every 18 hours the
virus the life of the virus is cut in
half so if you start with a thousand
particles of the virus in 18 hours
you're down to 500 in 18 hours after
that you're down to 250 and so on and so
forth that's important as I explained
the rest of the chart if you look at the
first three lines when you see the word
surface we're talking about non-porous
surfaces door handles stainless steel
and if you look at as the temperature
increases and as the humidity increases
with no Sun involved you can see how
drastically the half-life goes down on
that virus so the virus is dying at a
much more rapid pace just from exposure
to higher temperatures and just from
exposure to humidity if you look at the
fourth line you inject some the sunlight
into that you inject UV rays into that
the same effects on line two at 70 to 75
degrees with 80 percent humidity on the
surface and look at line four but now
you inject the Sun the half-life goes
from six hours to two minutes that's how
much of an impact the UV rays has on the
virus the last two lines are aerosols
what does it do in the air we have a
very unique capability
I was discussing this with the president
prior to coming out he wanted me to
convey it to you on how we do this I
believe were the only lab in the country
that has this capability but if you can
imagine a home depot bucket a 5-gallon
Home Depot bucket we were able to take a
particle and this was designed to
develop tanned design by our folks at
the end back we were able to take a
particle of the virus and suspend it in
the air inside of this drum and and and
hit it with various temperatures various
humidity levels multiple different kinds
of environmental conditions to include
sunlight and we're able to measure the
decay of that virus while it's suspended
in the air this is how we do our air
assault testing we worked with John
Hopkins Applied Physics lab and we
actually developed a larger drum to
actually more testing and four times the
size of that so this is the capability
that we bring to this effort
so in summary within the conditions
we've tested to date the virus in
droplets of saliva survives best in
indoors and dry conditions the virus
does not survive as well in droplets of
savate saliva and that's important
because a lot of testing being done is
not necessarily being done number one
with the coca 19 virus and number two in
saliva or respiratory fluids and thirdly
the virus dies the quickest in the
presence of direct sunlight under these
conditions and when you when you look at
that chart look at the aerosol as you
breathe it you put it in a room 70 to 75
degrees 20 percent humidity low humidity
it lasts the half-life is about an hour
but you get outside and it cuts down to
a minute and a half very significant
difference when it when it gets hit with
UV rays mr. president while there are
many unknown links in the Cova 19
transmission chain we believe these
trends can support practical decision
making to lower the risks associated
with the virus if I can have my next
slide and when that caught while that
comes up you'll see a number of some
practical applications for example
increasing the temperature and humidity
of potentially contaminated indoor
spaces appears to reduce the stability
of the virus and extra care may be
warranted for dry environments that do
not have exposure to solar light we're
also testing disinfectants readily
available we've tested bleach we've
tested isopropyl alcohol on the virus
specifically in saliva or in respite
fluids and I can tell you that bleach
will kill the virus in five minutes
isopropyl alcohol will kill the virus in
30 seconds and that's with no
manipulation no rubbing just bring it on
and leaving a go you rub it and it goes
away even faster we're also looking at
other disinfectants specifically looking
at the Cobra 19 virus in saliva this is
not the end of our work as we continue
to characterize this virus and integrate
our findings into practical applications
to mitigate exposure and transmission I
would like to thank the president thank
the vice president for their ongoing
support and leadership to the department
and for their work in addressing this
pandemic I would also like to thank the
scientists not only in S&T and the end
back but to the larger scientific and
R&D community thank you very much so a
question that probably some of you are
thinking of if you're totally into that
world which I find to be very
interesting so supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous whether it's
ultraviolet or just very powerful light
and I think you said that hasn't been
checked but you're gonna test it and
then I said supposing you brought the
light inside the body you can which you
can do either through the skin or in
some other way and I think you said
you're gonna test that - sounds
interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute
one minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number of along so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
gonna have to use medical doctors with
but it sounds it sounds interesting to
me so we'll see but the whole concept of
the light the way it kills it in one
minute that's that's pretty powerful
I see please
we'll be in a better place by early
summer does that mean you're gonna need
to extend the social distancing
guidelines until then we may go beyond
that we're gonna have to see where it is
and I think people are gonna know you're
gonna know I'm gonna know I think people
are gonna know just said Oh common sense
at some point we won't have to do that
but until we feel it's safe we're going
to be extending you have 23 cases where
new cases 23 states where new cases are
on decline what does that mean about
when the country can be safely reopened
to a normal point yeah but it means
we're gonna watch those cases very
carefully I think we've all gotten very
good at it we've gotten good at tracing
we see where the cases are where they're
going and we're gonna be watching it in
it's called containment at a certain
point we're gonna be able to contain and
you know when you see this a lot of
people have been talking about summer
maybe this is one of the reasons that
we've I once mentioned that maybe it
does go air with heat and light and
people didn't like that statement pretty
much the the fake news didn't like it at
all and I just threw it out as a
suggestion but it seems like that's the
case because when it's on a surface that
would last for a long time when that
surface is outside it goes away very
quickly it dies very quickly with the
Sun yeah go ahead you said yesterday
that you're gonna look into Senator
McConnell's suggestion for a lot of
states to declare bankruptcy versus the
alien yeah we'll look into it and I've
been looking into it I've been talking
to a lot of the different senators but I
don't want to talk about it now that was
a very interesting presentation go ahead
Jeff
well I wanted to talk about McConnell
suggestion that eight to the States
amounts to what I just told you I'm not
talking about it I'll talk about it
later
I'd like to talk about
as more interested mr. Brian yes you
thank you when you started your
presentation you described this as an
emerging result does this mean your
study is conclusive is there a more work
to do we're continuing that for example
on the aerosol side you notice the
figures were twenty percent humidity
we're looking at higher humidity levels
would expect that we even have a greater
impact on the virus we're looking at
other types of disinfectants and so
we're this is a we're as a scientific
community we're continuing to study the
virus to understand its characteristics
we've seen in the US are hot and humid
like New Orleans for example let me
explain if you look at the corona virus
as a chain with many links well we've
done through our study is we've
identified some of the weak links in
that chain that the virus transmission
of the virus depends upon we identify
that heat and humidity is a weakness in
that chain we've identified that
sunlight solar light UV rays as a
weakness in that chain that doesn't take
away the other activities the guidance
from the White House the guidance from
the CDC and others on the actions and
steps that people need to take to
protect themselves this is just another
another tool in our tool belt right
another another weapon in the fight that
we can add to it and in the summer we
know that summer-like conditions are
going to create an environment where the
transmission can be decreased and that's
an opportunity for us to get ahead the
president mentioned the idea of cleaners
is the fleet's of all America I there's
no scenario that that could be a
jacketed person is there you know I I'm
here to talk about finds that we had in
the study we don't do that within that
lab our labs
rejection about almost a blatant
sterilization of an area maybe it works
maybe it doesn't work but it certainly
has a big effect if it's on a stationary
object simplifying to months by saying
that it'd be better with the warmer
weather and the Sun coming out more and
more people would be outside than
staying inside their home it would be
irresponsible for us to say that we feel
that the summer is just gonna totally
kill the virus and then if it's a
free-for-all and that people ignore
those guys that is not the case we we
have an opportunity though to get ahead
with what we know now in factor that
into the decision makings for what opens
and what does and whatever other
conditions humidity and lack of humidity
that that would have an impact so that
on surfaces where it can be picked up it
will die fairly quickly in the summer
whereas in the winter it wouldn't thank
you so much yes mr. president when it's
exposed to UV rays take a playground
equipment for example the UV rays
hitting a piece of playground equipment
will kill the virus when it hits that
when it hits on the playground equipment
but underneath where the Sun does not
get if someone touched that and had it
on their hands it could still be there
right it has to be indirect light of the
UV rays and their hands are exposed to
the Sun will that kill it as though it
were a piece of metal or something else
not I don't want to say it will at the
same rate because it's a non-porous
service but we do know what we do know
is that we looked at the worst-case
scenario and the virus lives longer on
non-porous surfaces so porous surfaces
it doesn't live quite as long so in
theory what you said is correct this is
right yes mr. house governors who are
opening their states working on that
incorporate their findings of this study
into those guidelines I would leave that
up to the governor's this is a this is a
decision this factors into their
decision process as I mentioned with
knowing this knowledge and having this
knowledge as we continue to study and
further know what the virus does in how
it reacts it could impact the way a
governor will look at what he opens in a
state how he opens it in what
environments these things are opened up
but I leave that up to the governor's to
make that decision obviously remember
the advice is stay at home by the summer
could we be flipping that and saying
you'd be much better off being outside
would you be raised or the humidity that
Washington brings in August I would not
go contrary to the gains that have been
issued right now I think though to tell
you that if if I'm having an event with
my family I'm doing it in the driveway
or in the backyard not inside the house
with my children how much more research
how much more time to take to have
conclusive results but
we we first were able to receive the
virus back in February is when we
started testing and it is a
science-based approach science is a
process of the doctor can attest of that
it doesn't necessarily line up with
goals and targets and other things it is
what it is but we are now starting to
get results and and where every week or
two weeks we're starting to find out
something new and something different
and in talking to the to the task force
and the vice-president he's already
asked us to come to him every time we
come up with some new discoveries that
would could be that we could share to
the public yes sir have you compare
notes with your counterparts and other
foreign governments or in private
industry who might have been studying
the same thing and do their findings
show the same result that you found here
we have we do have a very good
partnership with a lot of our allies we
work closely with them on this
particular topic
we actually authored a document call the
master questions list if you go to DHS
S&T website we've already had about
17,000 hits on this document it actually
outlines with all the countries in the
world they're doing to fill the certain
gaps of knowledge that don't exist
within the virus and what we do know and
that is really what targets and drives
the science community state what don't
we know now so we don't duplicate what
other people have done so we've champion
that document it's well referenced and I
would encourage you to look at that what
would the federal government need to do
to take advantage of that time so if
there is a summer sort of ed with this
virus
what would the federal government need
to do to take advantage of that time to
be better prepared for a possible
resurgence I think a lot of people are
gonna go outside all of a sudden people
that didn't want to go outside they'll
be good to me this was very really a
very interesting meeting we've covered
in great detail and these are incredible
people at that we could call it a
laboratory because that's essentially
what it is it's a super laboratory it's
a lot of things going on to that
laboratory a lot of very interesting
things going
laboratory would you in other areas of
the government need to do on testing for
example or other things like that to be
prepared that came back in the hole why
would you take advantage of this summer
that's a it's actually a very good
question it's something the task force
already has begun discussing that we are
if a combination of factors let me say
again it states put into practice at the
guidelines to open up America again
implement a safe and responsible plans
to open up their economies along the
lines that the president unveiled a week
ago today people continue to properly
exercise social distancing as as is
recommended in each phase that in
combination with some of these findings
could well give us summer respite from
the coronavirus and our team is already
speaking about working on a continuous
basis through this summer every single
day we're increasing testing every
single day air bridge flights are coming
into the country there I can promise you
at the president's direction there will
be no letting up on making sure that our
hospitals have the equipment have the
personal protective supplies for medical
personnel
they'll be no letting up on the
development of therapeutics by our great
pharmaceutical companies are driving
toward a vaccine as soon as it is
possible to make available to the public
and there'll be no letting up on
continuing to scale testing already more
than anyone in the world but by next
fall we'll have a broad range of testing
a variety of different means and that's
why we say with confidence that should
the corona virus re-emerge at any point
next fall or next winter we will be
prepared to deal with it identify it do
the contact tracing and isolation to
ensure that that we deal with this
epidemic in the manner that we that we
deal with infectious diseases
mr. president on the subject of medical
research why have you stopped promoting
hydroxychloroquine
we've had a lot of very good results and
we had some results that perhaps aren't
so good I don't know I just read about
one but I also read many times good so I
haven't at all and I'd say it's a great
for malaria for lupus for other things
and we'll see what it is but I guess
Deborah they have many many studies
going on on that so we'll we'll be able
to we're now over 26 million new jobless
claims over five weeks yeah how the vice
president talked about this summer
getting better about how what do your
economists tell you about the time it's
gonna take the lead to you in the u.s.
to economists of comer well let me go
the week we know the rest of the
question right so I know a lot about
economists and the answer is they have
no idea I think I have as good an idea
as anybody and I think our economy will
start to pick up first substantially as
soon as the states get open and that's
happening as we speak and it's actually
very exciting and people are just just
thrilled to see it because our country
has to get back to work they want to get
back to work you see that whether it's a
demonstration or just in talking to
people they're going to get back to work
and they're gonna get back to work very
fast states are advanced I look at gavin
newsom was dissin was very nice today he
wrote a beautiful statement about we
sent him a lot of a lot of things that
he needed okay things different things
that he needed we got we got it taken
care of they've done very well in
California's you know they're doing
really well in Florida they're doing
well in a lot of places New York and New
Jersey got hit very hard they're doing
very well
I spoke again with Governor Cuomo with
governor Murphy they're doing they're
doing a great job and here's the thing
we have to see they got hit hard
everyone close together tight end people
don't realize New Jersey is very tight
you realize that because you've been
covering it for a long
but very tight New York obviously is
very tight they're doing a terrific job
I think for the most part I'll be able
to tell you when it's all over but a lot
of the governors have done a really
terrific job some I don't think have to
be honest but we'll be talking about the
future yes go ahead a new interview
today with Time magazine doctor kouchi
said that the u.s. is not in a situation
where you can say we are where they want
to be with regard to testing capacity he
said we need much more testing capacity
as well as tests so why do you keep
saying we have a tremendous testing
capacity and do we have a national
strategy that goes beyond track you just
what the states are doing the interest
yes and the answer is as you know and as
I've said many times we're very advanced
and testing other countries are calling
us to find out what are we doing and by
the way within two weeks you'll see
numbers and you'll see different forms
of testing just like we came up with the
avid laboratories machine which gives it
to you in five minutes that everybody
wants everybody's asking can we get that
but you can only make them so fast but
as you know we've done more testing than
every other nation combined and that's a
big statement and you know when they
talk about different tests and different
things we're also a bigger nation than
most and so when they look at statistics
because statistically we're doing
phenomenally in terms of mortality in
terms of all of the different elements
that you can judge when you look Germany
and ourselves are doing very well
we are very accurate in the reporting of
numbers in fact I'll go a step further
as you know in New York they actually
added quite a few deaths to a list that
was done in New York and they added a
number of deaths were very very highly
accurate and then you'll look at certain
lists of other countries some are so
obvious just to look at where obviously
the number is ridiculous in the form of
low because they're not accurate counts
they're not even close to accurate
counts in fact they're insulting to look
at them so we've done
very well again testing we're doing very
well on testing we've tested far more
than anybody else anywhere in the world
and within a short period of time you'll
be hearing about new tests that are
coming out that are gonna be incredible
just not no I don't agree with him on
that no I think we're doing a great job
when testing I don't agree if he said
that I don't agree with them yes
considering ways to get the to ramp up
production of that Abra traffic yeah
well they're doing it I'll tell you
Steve they're doing it at a level that
they've never done it before Abbott is a
great company it's a very big highly
respected company they came up with this
machine where you do it I've done it
both ways I've done it this way and I
didn't like it and I've done it the
Abbott way where you literally just
touch and five minutes later you know
the answer and we use them in the white
house I think you folks have been given
that opportunity which is much more
pleasant than the first way that they
looked at you right we're making them
hundreds of thousands of machines the
advantage to the other tests and the
laboratory tests so we can get millions
and millions of those tests done it
takes a day or two days but you know
because it's really a delivery situation
more than anything else the test itself
goes quickly once it gets to the
laboratory but as we have found and as
we have I think she'll never regret in
the room we have many laboratories we
have that we have so many laboratories
nobody nobody a lot of the governor's
did not know that we have this capacity
but we have many laboratories all over
our country every state has laboratories
and some have a lot of them so I think
we will we will come up with things as
time goes by again when I started we
ended up we started with nothing
essentially what we started with a
broken test a test that didn't work we
started with a tested at very few people
not millions of people the problem is if
we did 350 if we did 350 million tests
one for each person the media would say
oh you should have done two for each
person no matter what you do it doesn't
make any difference it's just like the
ventilators I talk about it all the time
nobody ever mentions ventilators one of
the hardest things uh ventilators and
now we're making thousands a week
thousand
the ventilators and they're calling from
Mexico they're calling from many
countries I've received today four calls
would it be possible to send ventilators
alright I get four calls today I got
three calls yesterday no country is
equipped like we are we have 11 we have
11 different places making ventilators
our country as you know doesn't need
them now our governors are very happy
but that's different than tests because
with the test you can always say oh we
need one no I think we've done
incredibly well with obviously with
ventilators would we also have
500-million masks 500-million masks that
are very shortly going to be here we've
made millions of masks we have ordered
millions of myths that have arrived and
been distributed we gave one Hospital in
New York City 300,000 masks before the
virus they were using 10,000 and now we
got them 300,000 and they got rid of
them very quick which quickly which I
sort of say how did that happen why
because they became very valuable the
masks I say how did that happen
but we got we have we've done an amazing
job and we've worked with the governors
and when the governors weren't able
again they're the first line when they
weren't able to get something like
ventilates they couldn't get ventilators
they could have bought him you could
have bought him but most of them many of
them chose not to so they all needed
ventilators we got the job done we have
I'll be introducing the team when we're
finished with this whole nightmare this
whole curse this whole plague but the
team that worked on the ventilators was
incredible and the team that worked and
it's a little bit interchangeable but
the team that's working on the testing
is truly an incredible team these are
brilliant people and they're doing it
for the country they're not doing it for
other reasons some have been very
successful they're doing it for the
country yes the house is not past that
you were here the relief bill I'm
signing it
tonight as you know there's no aid to
states and localities in that bill meant
Mitch McConnell of course has talked
about States seeking bankruptcy
protection
he's also his office referred to this is
a the idea of 18 states is a blue state
bailout what do you say to that do you
do you agree with that or do you agree
with Governor Cuomo that that is a
vicious attack on these states that is
attacked but certainly some people do
look at it that way I've spoken to Mitch
about it I've spoken to numerous
senators about it and we're working with
senators that are on the other side of
the issue and we'll see what happens but
we're looking to do what's right for the
people of this country we're looking to
do what's right for a particular state
and we'll see what happens but it's
certainly the next thing we're going to
be discussing because some states have
in all fairness John some states have
not done very well for many years so
long before the virus came you know you
can't blame the plague this horrible
plague that came in and all of a sudden
you know they can't blame that you look
at Illinois he's got a lot of problems
long before the virus came in and so
we'll be talking about it it'll be a
subject for a period of time and right
now we've we've made this incredible
deal for the workers and for small
business and I'm very happy that Harvard
didn't get covered we actually never
sent them the check but they were very
nice about it we never sent him the the
money the old-fashioned where's the
check the new way has sent him the money
and we didn't send him the money and but
they were very understanding and they
were very nice about it so was Princeton
so with Stanford so were a number of
other schools that you just don't
associate with this money so were big
companies as you know you know many of
them it was a relatively small amount of
money compared to the whole very small
amount of money compared but we want it
to be fair we want it to go to the
people that are supposed to go to ideas
that are going to be great for the
people of this country and if we can
help states we're always going to help
States now there's different ways of
helping States some ways are better than
others so we're looking it is
interesting that the states
in trouble do happen to be blue it is
interesting you know if you look around
I mean the states that seemed to have
the problem happened to be Democrat and
Jersey got hit by this you know there
were a lot of trouble long before the
plague came and they were you know a lot
of problems long before the play came I
spoke with Governor Cuomo Bevin spoke to
Governor Murphy about it I spoke with
Gavin Newsom about it and we speaking to
a lot of people about it because it's
probably gonna be the next thing on the
list a lot of people understand very
well what mitch is saying and they also
understand the other side of the the
problem and I'll be speaking about it
we're going to do the right thing for
our country the right thing for our
country and the right thing for a lot of
great people okay yeah president after
the presentation we just saw that the
heat and the humidity is it dangerous
for you to make people think they would
be safe by going outside in the heat
considering that so many people are
dying in Florida considering that this
virus has had an outbreak in Singapore
places that are hot and are we good the
new headline is Trump is people to go
outside that's dangerous here we go
same old group you ready I hope people
enjoy the Sun and if it has an impact
that's great I'm just hearing this not
really for the first time I mean there's
been a rumor that you know a very nice
room or that you go outside in the Sun
or you have heat and it does have an
effect on other viruses but now we get
it from one of the great laboratories of
the world I have to say covers a lot
more territory than just this is this is
probably an easy thing relatively
speaking for you I would like you to
speak to the medical doctors to see if
there's any way that you can apply light
and heat to cure you know if you could
and maybe you can't maybe you can't
again I say maybe you can maybe you
can't I'm not a doctor but I'm like a
person that has a good you know what
never have you ever heard of that the
heat and the light relative to certain
viruses yes but relative to this virus
it's certainly fever yeah is a good
thing when you have a fever it helps
your body respond but not as I've not
seen I think it's a great thing to look
at I mean okay Lee sir you're the
president and people tuning in to these
briefings they want to get information
and guidance and want to know what to do
they're not looking good I'm the
president and your fake news and you
know what I'll say to you I'll say very
nicely I know you will I know you well
because I know the guy I see what he
writes he's a total faker so are you
ready are you ready are you ready it's
just a suggestion from a brilliant lab
by a very very smart
perhaps brilliant man he's talking about
son he's talking about heat and you see
the numbers so that's it that's all I
have I'm just here to present talent I'm
here to present ideas because we won
ideas to get rid of this thing and if he
is good and is good Johnson & Johnson is
working they're also working together
you're many companies working together
on a vaccine then if you think that
scales they can scale up production and
the pharmaceutical companies would be
able to do that quickly if we had a
vaccine
it'll be scaled up very quickly in fact
some of the companies Johnson & Johnson
is one is scaling up already before they
have the final answer a number of
companies are doing that you'll save a
lot of time the normal is you scale up
after I have to say the FDA has been
fantastic
Stephen Han dr. Han has been fantastic
they're moving along rapidly rapidly
would you say timescale when not one for
time scale because then the the media
the so-called so-called media lamestream
media will say he said a time I don't
want to say times because every time I
say a time if you don't hit it they'll
say so I don't want to talk about time
but I will say that there's been
tremendous progress made over the last
month
that's a very quick question you spoke
to Boris Johnson this week I just wonder
how he sounded how he was like when do
you think every packet were called me a
few days ago I will tell you he sounded
incredible I was actually surprised I
thought it'd be like Oh Donald how are
he was ready to go I could I'm very
surprised to tell you this it's like the
old Boris tremendous energy tremendous
Drive I was very surprised because he
called me almost you know pretty close
to when he got out of the hospital I
think he's doing great
I think he's doing great he was so sharp
and energetic pretty incredible he's an
incredible guy he's a friend of ours and
and a friend of mine he loves our
country he loves his country a lot but
he loves our country respects our
country and they're lucky to have him
over there please you might reach out to
kim jongmin directly but also that you
were working to find out if those
reports about him being impossible
medical trouble were true I'm wondering
if you've either I hope he's not in
medical trouble I hope anything from
here we are you would have been in a war
with North Korea if I didn't get elected
president remember I was gonna be the
one that took us into war with my first
day in office okay here we are look at
what's happened withdrawal
we're bringing people home we're not
going to serve as policemen all over the
world I don't want to be policemen all
over the world and yet I've really built
our military to a level that has never
been built that before everybody's ever
recognized by the face go ahead I think
the report was incorrect let me just put
it that way I think the report was done
by a network that was incorrect I'm
hearing they used old documents but I
that's what I hear I hear the report was
an incorrect report I hope it was an
incorrect report I don't want to say
pointed to me just a quick
about that so you haven't made any
contact though just to make sure though
they're worth Koreans I don't want to
sit I won't say that okay we had a good
relationship with North Korea as good as
you can have I mean we have a good
relationship with North Korea I have a
good relationship with Kim jong-un and I
hope he's okay
and somebody would say oh that's
terrible no it's not terrible I hope
he's okay
and I think it was a fake report done by
CNN the problem is you know right the
truth so you know as far as I'm
concerned I want to go I want to go to
the CNN is fake news don't talk to me go
ahead please okay next question
[Music]
first one could you talk about your
decision making process on Georgia
generation well you know you know you
said yesterday that you totally got a
Georgia your concern had a good talk
with the governor of Georgia in a week
you spoke and you did not convey this
kind of message whether they convey the
message I didn't like the fact that he's
leaving certain things I want the states
to open more than he does much more than
he does but I didn't like to see spa's
at this early stage in ordered the
doctors is that a correct statement
Deborah I didn't like to see spas
opening frankly I didn't like to see a
lot of things happening and I wasn't
happy with it and I wasn't happy with
Brian Kemp I wasn't at all happy because
and I could have done something about it
if I wanted to but I'm saying let the
governor's do it but I wasn't happy with
Brian Kemp spas beauty parlors tattoo
parlors I know that's dead and by the
way I want them to open excuse me excuse
me I want them to open and I want him to
open as soon as possible and I want the
state to open but I wasn't happy with
Brian Kemp I will tell you that right
now yeah go ahead
classy to fight you on that no and you
know you didn't define me at all that's
your language he didn't define me you
know what happened I said you make your
own decision I told him that I said
you're not in the guidelines but I'm
letting you make your own decision but I
want people to be safe and I want the
people in Georgia to be safe and I don't
want this thing to flare up because
you're deciding to do something that is
not in the guidelines and I went to
Deborah and dr. foul she and other
people and they weren't thrilled about
it and I could have stopped him but I
decided and we all agreed they got to
watch it closely so we'll see what
happens I told him very distinctly I
said Mike was there I said you do what
you think is best but if you ask me am i
happy about it I'm not happy about it
and I'm not happy about Brian Kemp go
ahead a question for dr. Burks if I may
mr. president about the the rate of the
decline of the curve in the US view and
the vice president tonight talking about
meaningful progress promising progress
could you speak to the rate of decline
of cases information from other
countries that would inform us about the
decline yes many of you and I've spoken
all of you from this podium about
there's weekend's difference in
reporting often a spike on Monday if you
look at Monday's over Mondays if you
look at seven-day reporting we are
starting to go down we have a lot we had
a long flat peak largely driven a course
by New York which is about 45 or so
percent of the cases as you New York
goes down so will the rest of the
country have a decline even more
accelerated I want to say though we have
had outbreaks we've had outbreaks in
specific prisons we've had outbreaks in
specific nursing homes we've had
outbreaks and specific plants and when
that happens that adds to 300 400 cases
on that single date so we track very
carefully not only what the country is
doing but what each state is doing each
county is doing and we look at Delta
changes
across all of the counties so that we
find early warning signals for these
types of outbreaks because we want to
prove we want the whole country to go
down but we also want to prevent the
outbreaks before they are looking
forward to November the election keep
you're given the risk that the flu and
the chronic problem do you think that is
a risk you'll be there'll be some there
will be lack of agreement like
legitimacy is the results in a very
close election and people start saying
well a whole bunch people can go and
vote I can't tell you what's gonna
happen in there like yeah I a great
question I can't tell you what's gonna
happen we have a sleepy guy in a
basement of a house that the press is
giving a free pass to who doesn't want
to do debates because of kovat and lots
of things are happening right and I
watched a couple of interviews and I say
oh I look forward to this but they're
keeping him sheltered because of the
corona virus and he's not moving around
he's not moving too much and then I
watched what the press does to the
Republican Party and to me in particular
we had the greatest economy ever put
together we were doing this is a month
in Africa we were doing numbers alike
the likes of which we've never done
African American Asian American Hispanic
American best employment numbers ever in
the history of our country our
employment numbers the best in the
history of our country almost a hundred
and sixty million people the stock
market record numbers many many times
during my tenure many many times but now
we have a country that we had a close
because of this and frankly if we didn't
close it we would have lost millions of
people possibly but certainly we would
have lost a million people you take the
high number and cut it in half cut it in
half again but whether it would have
been six hundred seven hundred eight
hundred you take a look at at the
travesty that there is you take a look
at this horrible horrible scene of
hospitals with bodies and black body
bags right multiply that times 10 15 or
even 20
because that would have happened so we
did the right thing so far we did the
right thing
so far we've called it right we've
mobilized like it was a military
operation and it was largely a military
operation between ventilators and
testing and so many other things that
we've had a lot of good partners not all
good partners but we had a lot of good
partners gavin newsom today thanked us
very much gavin newsom
california thanked us so much for
getting him all the things that he
needed so he can keep going and keep
doing a good job we got it to him today
tomorrow we're getting him even more
would have been harder for him to get it
than us we agreed to get it we got it on
time he said promises made promises kept
he actually said that in a statement
today we've done a good job we've gotten
very little credit for the great job
we've done because of the media because
the media is not an honest media in my
opinion much of it not all of it we have
some great reporters that I have
tremendous respect but much of the media
is not honest so I can't tell you about
the election you have a Democrat Party
and you have a large portion of the
media automatically giving the guy a
pass he's been given a pass whether or
not he's going to be the nominee I have
no idea but he's getting a pass and the
media isn't covering the great job that
we've done whether it's Mike's task
force which has been incredible whether
it's the way we've mobilized in a war
like operation to build these incredibly
complex and very expensive ventilators
they're very expensive to build and very
complex the job we've done has been an
amazing job and I'm not talking about me
I'm talking about everybody I'm talking
about the generals the Admirals Debra
and Tony and and now bill I mean
something we hadn't heard today so I
can't tell you what's gonna happen with
the election I think that had we not
gone through a fake Russia Russia Russia
deal and impeachment hoax it was a total
hoax from the day I got elected but you
know it wasn't the day it was many
months before I got elected this has
been a witch hunt that was illegal it
was an illegal witch hunt it was illegal
and with all of that I'm doing fine
because the people see we're doing a
great job and you know what we'll
continue to do a great job if we had an
honest press this country would be even
greater thank you that was